Republicans tearing into President Biden
for a missing deadline release
information about the Wuhan lab's
possible links to the origins of the
covid pandemic Congress voted
unanimously back in March to give the
United States 90 days to make that Intel
public but that deadline came and went
yep Biden Administration didn't cough
that up the White House directed Fox to
dni Avril Haynes office her office said
they've been carefully declassifying the
report house intelligence committee
chair Mike Turner had this to say
this certainly is a deadline that was
passed that was put in law she's going
to have to have some explaining to do in
addition to produce these documents when
these documents are are made public and
and they're red they're going to be in
sharp contrast to the unclassified
version that was put out by the bite
Administration I think that'll also give
people pause because they'll believe
that the administration was being
disingenuous when they released their
unclassified statement
fox has now confirmed a prominent United
States funded scientist who worked on
coronavirus projects is one of three
Chinese researchers who became very ill
with an unspecified illness during the
initial covet outbreak
well those things were talked about but
we were stickered on Twitter if we asked
questions about them cat kamek
Republican congresswoman of Florida
member of the Energy and Commerce
Committee and the select subcommittee on
the weaponization of the federal
government great to see you today what
should we be focusing on as we learn
this new information
well Harris it seems like every day is a
game of whack-a-mole with this
Administration if it's not one thing
it's another you know we're seeing that
this deadline has been missed in
conjunction with this bombshell report
that has been verified that patient zero
actually worked in the taxpayer-funded
Wuhan lab so that in itself right there
means that there is so much more for us
to uncover but of course what we've seen
in the past from the bite Administration
is them continually missing statutory
statutorily declared deadlines like the
budget for example so you have to ask
yourself is this incompetence or is this
malice at this point neither is
acceptable what we need to do is
continue to uncover all of these
documents but more than anything the
American people deserve to see the
unclassified document they need to know
the truth about the origins of covid and
what the administration and Congress has
known all along it's that transparency
and accountability that Americans
regardless of party have been demanding
and I think that they're hesitant to do
so because they recognize that this
report that they are quote unquote
attempting to declassify and has been
taking so long that it flies in the face
of the political narrative that they
have been pushing out there they're
going to have some explaining to do and
as we know Mr Clean he's on Perpetual
Duty with the white house they are
constantly walking back statements this
is going to be one more game example of
that yeah it also complicates where we
are with China right now I mean how can
you hold their feet to the fire when you
hold no leverage which is what some of
my guests like representative Mike
McCall said recently with our secretary
of state sitting down with President XI
of China we just they got us all right
let's move on after Hunter Biden's plea
deal with the Department of Justice
house oversight chair James Comer
promised to forge ahead with its
investigation ongoing into the Biden's
top House Republicans totally on board
if you are the president's son you get a
sweetheart view now this does nothing to
our investigation it actually should
enhance our investigations because the
doj should not be able to withhold any
information now Hunter's not out of the
woods yet though and uh the the house uh
but the oversight committee is on the
issue of the source of these funds
because there's no real Clarity I have a
just a fundamental question if Joe
Biden's not the big guy who is so that's
what we're digging into beforethcoming
with this let us see the information
one op-ed headline Hunter Biden's plea
deal reeks asking how it could take five
years to come up another argues the
hunter Biden's plea deal is proof
Democrats are The Untouchables in Joe's
America
the New York Post cover highlighting the
gun that sparked the charges with the
headline hunter gets away with it okay
that there's so many pictures and videos
and I know it's offensive but it's
everywhere and I he's prolific
uh Harris this is if this isn't Democrat
privilege I don't know what is this is a
double standard the hypocrisy at the
highest levels the elite Untouchables
Call It Whatever you will but this
highlights the two-tiered justice system
that we are seeing right now in America
this is the destruction of some of the
the most important pillars in America
and our constitutional republic you
wonder why Americans are losing faith in
the media they're losing faith in the
justice system it's because of things
just like this he gets two years
probation a slap on the wrist this guy
faced his first gun chart or his first
drug charge in 1988 the year that I was
born 35 years this guy has been building
up a record a rap sheet and all he gets
is a slap on the wrist and two years
probation never mind the fact that he
was not eligible for the program that
has allowed him to divert into probation
rather than face trial rather than face
real jail time that right there is a
slap in the face and it goes against the
very principles and the Very guiding
documents that are published on the doj
website right now so again I think we
have to get to the bottom of this where
there's smoke there's fire just because
they give him a little bit of a slap on
the wrist does not mean that we just
turn away and say oh what's done is done
we need to get to the bottom of it and
if they have nothing to hide they'll
come forward they'll stop obstructing
what we need to do in terms of
Investigations congresswoman kamik I
want to bring you back on another day I
I really want to dig deep into the next
time we talk what regular Americans like
some of the rappers that have come out
now and said they face like Kodak Black
just talked to Fox News digital he faced
something similar he didn't get the same
treatment as a rap artist that that Joe
Biden's son got I mean it's it's going
to get interesting so glad to have you
in Focus that's Wesley Snipes the actor
he'll tell you oh there's a yes thank
you good to see you good to see you hey
everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me and
my co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcaneny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights